guys have you recently heard about the  news of the lunar eclipse and what  exactly is a lunar eclipse so when the  earth comes in between the Sun and the  Moon it produces a shadow which either  partially or completely covers the Moon  this phenomenon is called as a lunar  eclipse now a total lunar eclipse occurs  when the darkest part of the Earth's  Shadow called the Umbra covers the moon  and guys this year there have been two  instances where this phenomenon of total  lunar eclipse has happened the most  recent one being on the 8th of November  2022 which is very recent indeed the  next total Lunar Eclipse is going to be  happening on the 14th of March 2025  three years from now let's make sure we  don't miss that experience now guys  total lunar eclipse produces a  phenomenon called blood moon comment  down below what it means and for more  such interesting facts follow our  channels